I want to talk about something that I I
sort of have been hesitant to because I
feel there's gonna be a lot of backlash
against me for this but over the weekend
i stopped that a couple of Trump
anti-trump protests in Massachusetts I
won't say which one specifically I a lot
of people i know personally were at some
of these i was concerned by what I saw
and a lot of these were none of these
were violent to be clear and of course I
am against all violence and destruction
of property I was disappointed with the
perspectives that were predominant and
dominating at these anti-trump protests
I went to and it was just a lot of
identity politics and I I want to be
super clear we're only a week out from
the election a lot of people are
understandably upset a lot of people are
understandably scared and if that's why
these anti-trump protests have been
heavily focused at least the ones i went
to on identity politics and fears of I'm
speaking as an accent sort of insert
your your identity there uh I totally
get that and that's fine as long as that
this is going to shift into something
more productive but at none of these
rallies were there any discussions of
climate change were there any
discussions of economics were there any
discussions of trade and globalization
and employment and I'm just sort of
worried Pat and I I i know people email
me and say David this doesn't speak for
all the rallies are all the protesters
when I heard that half of the people who
attended one rally in Oregon or
Washington against Trump hadn't voted
you have a right to complain whether you
voted or not but when I hear that half
of the attendees never voted to begin
with which by the way could have
completely changed the outcome of the
election and then I see only discussions
of identity politics and a lot of
buzzwords and discussions that that
don't don't really lead to any kind of
action I am concerned and I'm putting it
out there and I don't say this as an
insult I say this hopefully as a wake-up
call that we need to take this energy
and make it something productive we need
to be planning very specifically what it
is that we are going to do as
progressives and the you know if you
look at Maslow's hierarchy of needs it's
hard to focus on those needs
the top of the pyramid if the base of
the pyramid is unstable and that
includes feeling like you are physically
safe not feeling like you're at risk of
butter no some kind of second tier
status in the United States I totally
get that but we need to figure out how
can we number one work with Trump
supporters not that we're going to like
the decision they made but where is
their overlap so that we can take the
areas where Trump and Bernie Sanders
agreed and go forward there
legislatively but also be set up for the
2017 gubernatorial elections that there
are for the 2018 midterms for the 2020
election for blocking outrageous Supreme
Court Justice nominees all of these
things need to be planned very
specifically and I'm a little worried
because of what i saw these protests
nothing violent no destruction of
property but I saw a very significant
lack of focus on the specifics of what
need to be done right I'm sure a lot of
these protesters aren't clear as to what
their endgame is because when you
protest something like the climate
change that's going on or police
brutality yeah there there's policy
proposals that you want to see enacted
to combat them right right but Donald
Trump's can be President for the next
four years no matter what he's going to
be our president whether you like it or
not and so I'm really confused as to
what they think the endgame is and some
of them said we're not here to prevent
Trump from becoming the president were
here just as a show that there is
significant angst and opposition to his
presidency the best way to have have uh
shown that would have been for more
people to vote we're in very fused in
most states more than half of the
population did not vote Massachusetts
fortunately is one of the states were
more than half the population did vote
Hillary Clinton defeated non-voters as
well as Trump here in Massachusetts this
is hugely concerning to me this is not a
negative coverage of those who want to
activate this is a concern about the
fact that we need to be more organized
in our activism I have no time for the
voice mail today we've got some great
stories on the bonus show sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership